this episode is sponsored by rocket
money if your New Year's goals are to
manage your budget better and save money
you need rocket money stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
that's rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
I'm so excited this weekend I'm going to
be in Phoenix January 6th and 7th you
can get tickets at Esther onice.com hey
sluggies I hope you're enjoying this
episode
um my new solo podcast Annie wood is now
out on youtube.com Annie Letterman at a
brand new date and time it's on
Thursdays at 8 A.M Pacific 11 A.M
Eastern I have been having so much fun
live chatting with all of you guys
during the premiere so check it out if
you can make it on time it's a blast
also I'm on the road as usual and I love
meeting you guys it's been so fun you
can see me next I have a new date for
Burbank Flappers January 14th there's
one show only let's sell out and have a
blast
um I'll then be in Madison Wisconsin at
the end of January on the 27th and 28th
I'll be in Dania Beach Florida February
3rd and 4th Washington DC February 24th
and 25th and I'll be in Seattle I'm so
excited I've been waiting to come see
you guys March 10th and 11th and Tampa
at the end of March and then I'll be in
Danforth Canada in April all all those
dates are changing they're being added
please go to annieleterman.com shows to
check those out and get tickets I can't
wait to meet you guys so much new merch
so many fun things new jokes I love you
I'll see you soon and see you in anyone
[Music]
so welcome to trash Tuesday today we
have a guest we're very excited about
Eileen Kelly welcome thank you Eileen
you are like basically this like Tumblr
creature creature you're like an iconic
creature Tumblr you're like very sex
positive you talk a lot about mental
health you have your own podcast going
deep going going mental going crazy
going mental
um
so yeah we're just like excited to have
you and like learn from you is that okay
yes I'm excited to be here super excited
um I feel like you're the smart girl we
are not
so you might be the brains of this
episode okay and so you um you um
studied gender studies right I studied
gender studies and then I did like a sex
education program in San Francisco
um yeah and then I used to do like
mainly mostly sex ed was like the brunt
of my career and I would go and like
speak at schools and did a lot of really
cool stuff with Planned Parenthood and a
bunch of different non-profits and
organizations and then I had like my own
issues with mental health and ended up
stepping away from my career in life in
New York and I went and did like a
mental health treatment at a hospital in
Boston for like half a year with no
phone oh well I know no phone no
computer what that which this was like
right when coved was breaking I actually
discharged from the hospital like right
into kova was it voluntary yeah okay
yeah I went voluntarily um because I've
been three times involuntary yeah but we
could talk about that
um yeah cause it's a residential program
so you have to like want to do it and
it's really really rigorous so there was
like all these crazy tests I mean I
could talk more about the experience but
that kind of was a natural pivot in my
life to shifting towards mental health
even though I feel like the two are
really connected like sexual and mental
health I mean it's really just comes
down to like communication
and like speaking about your emotions
and being able to yeah control them
better
um and so yeah that's kind of where life
has taken me and then when what was
happening in your life right before you
said okay like I need this break like
yeah how did you know I just had like
such debilitating anxiety like I
couldn't eat I'd like lost a [ __ ] ton of
weight
um wasn't sleeping just like wasn't
functioning I wasn't able to work
um I had to like take time off from work
and then I was like this is not normal
like I'm not doing okay
um
and yeah then I started I first did like
an outpatient program in New York and
then I pretty quickly knew that I needed
a higher level of care so I was like I
still feel like [ __ ] like I go home
after being in an outpatient program all
day and I feel just as crazy if not
crazier
um living alone I was living alone at
the time and going through the throes of
like a really horrible breakup and it
was just like a lot emotionally that I
didn't know how to deal with and someone
yeah recommended this program and I
actually had dated someone that had gone
to the same Hospital crazy enough and he
was like I really think you should go
you can always leave if you want to if
it's not helping and so I just committed
and I went to this program and it it's a
six-month program wow well they actually
kind of trick you I always say no no I'm
serious it's a 60-day minimum is what
they say but then you get there and
everyone's been there for like five
months six months and you're like okay
um and then most people go right into an
outpatient program for another six
months in Boston so a lot of people go
there like for a year and so
I don't know when I think about it I'm
like people are really at their rock
bottom
to commit like a half a year a year of
your life right away and and I'm
assuming people fly from all over the
world or even oh yeah there are people
from all over the world yeah
um yeah I mean it's one of the best and
oldest psychiatric hospitals in in the
country in the world so it's part of
Harvard too so they have a lot of
ongoing like new research and
medications and doctors and like you get
a whole team but like you have to be
Sick Enough right to
even get into this program if that makes
sense right like it's hard to get in
yeah just no no I just mean like there's
only certain amount of sloths yeah and
like I remember a lot of like the stigma
I would get from family and friends
because I was so
like on from an external point of view I
was so high functioning like people
didn't really know what was going on
internally for me so they didn't see
like how bad I was doing but I think
that is the scariest part is being high
functioning because like no one like you
don't have the Hallmark Hues of someone
like going through like a nervous
breakdown that's what I always say just
about mental mental illness mental
health is it's invisible like it's not
like a physical illness
um in terms of like you could see
someone in a wheelchair you could see
someone with a broken leg
um and so I feel like it never get it
has so much more stigma and they don't
treat them the same I had someone on my
podcast
um
have you ever read the book or seen the
movie Brain on Fire
I I've seen part of the movie okay so
basically she has this like she had this
neurological condition that um
was giving her psychosis essentially but
it's actually because her brain was
swelling so it was a physical illness
but she talked about how she kept going
to the hospital and going to the
hospital and at first they thought she
was schizophrenic like she got
misdiagnosis schizophrenic and bipolar
and all these things they couldn't
figure out what was going wrong with her
and then once she switched and they
figured out that it was this brain
condition she said her level of care
changed like completely night and day
um and just in terms of how they treat
mental illness versus physical illness
like in a hospital setting and just like
the research and stigma so that's kind
of what I've been trying to do is just
talk about it I guess yeah I felt like
also because my issue was binge eating
and I felt like because sorry donor is
so annoying but I love her
um because
my addiction was like to eating a lot of
food I felt like I no one would take it
seriously because it's not like I was
like drinking alcohol or doing drugs
which I had family members who had
struggled with those kinds of addiction
and like that was really serious and I
remember this phone call I had to make
to my parents where I was like no like I
get it it's just food and I just like
overeating but like we need to start
looking at this like I'm an alcoholic
like I'm struggling and it is I don't
know I yeah it's hard to like get people
to see that yeah it's the internal
experience it's like even someone who
has OCD for example like you don't know
what it's like to step into their mind
and hear those thoughts on Loop
um my poor mother she has OCD and
Symmetry and I just see like the wheels
turning and I know that she struggles
with anything that is out of her
um like
when she puts I tiny things that we
don't even consider like how the hangers
are spaced in a closet right like for
her that is a big big big deal like it
can consume her her whole being and
she'll sit there for two hours and she
has to space out the hanger a certain
way or else like she just feels like
this huge discomfort for the rest of the
day and the way she folds clothes and I
just like I it's it's visible to me but
otherwise from a person who's not in her
life day to day she is 62 years old with
a six pack who's just this physical
specimen of a woman who's raised who's
just a strong woman who's raised two
daughters you know mostly Alone
um but no she struggles with the tiniest
things day to day and I just like have
so much like empathy for her doesn't
that sort of just make you this whole
conversation make you feel like everyone
literally everyone is struggling like
there's no even chance they're not right
like we're all [ __ ] up and struggling
yeah I think so I mean even doing this
doing the podcast I've been doing like
I'll get messages from like
like daily like 20 messages especially
when we put out an episode maybe it'll
be more than that of like hey I listened
to your episode on OCD or I listen to
your episode and personality disorders
and like either I have a family member
or a friend that's struggling or I
relate to this and I'm and like so many
people just came out of the woodwork and
so really does make me selfishly like
not feel as alone but also just to
connect with other people and like
you're saying yeah a lot of people are
struggling
yeah and it's a tough thing because it's
like the infrastructure to support just
like mental health in general is like
really poor because I remember
um when I was in high school and I was
put on a 5150 like it was hard to find a
bed
for a girl like me a place like you know
I ended up going to bhc in Alhambra and
I was there twice but even then it's
like here's a girl who just attempted
suicide but it was difficult to place me
in in uh by bed I mean like there's no
space for me right everything is like
packed you know and
um I just remember thinking to myself
it's like well [ __ ] if I'm this extreme
of a case this was a very it wasn't like
a silent thing I wasn't silently
suffering like I had an attempt at my
life and they still had trouble finding
me a bed like imagine anyone else who is
not obviously like attempting suicide
but is struggling and like you know it's
less visible we're all on our own we're
all on our [ __ ] home yeah well I
think there's a disconnect between the
medical community like my experience
having been in the hospital for like
psychiatric stuff it's like in and out
like especially if you have had an
attempt for example like they keep you
for usually as long as your insurance
will let you which is not that long
mostly they're prioritizing like
physical health okay is this person like
if they tried to overdose let's you know
get them healthy enough to then
discharge like it's never really about
are you okay or asking those questions
it's like we treat you kind of
yeah just like the physical body
symptomatically symptomatically exactly
are there any like specific top favorite
most useful tools that you took with you
from the experience of being oh man yes
so the program I did is called DBT
dialectical behavioral therapy and it's
basically
not talked I mean it's just not talk
therapy it's
um you learn behavioral skills that you
can practice and it's been shown in
research that kind of the more you do
them then you actually can because your
brain is constantly evolving like you
have new Pathways so you can kind of
change your by changing your behavior
you can change your thoughts essentially
so it's not like talk talk therapy where
sometimes you're like talking in a loop
like I was in talk therapy for years and
years and I was like I know why I do
things like I know my childhood trauma I
know X Y and Z but in terms of actually
making the change to do something
different I felt very stuck and so
that's what this program really helped
me is it's like okay they don't even yes
you talk about your history and things
because that is important and there are
multiple components of why people
struggle there's usually a genetic
component and then usually it's also
environment
um environmental like nature versus
nurture so it's like the mix of the two
um
and some of these sorry I'm like losing
my train of thought
yeah some of these behavioral skills are
as simple as like if you're having a
panic attack I'm sure you guys have seen
this on Tick Tock like dumping your face
in ice water that's a literal DBT skill
like I'm not even kidding I went there
as what
23 year old I think 23 or 24. and I'm
like why I this could have been so
useful for me even in like middle school
or like my first breakup with a
boyfriend just like little simple
they're called skills
um but also it's how do you
like how do you talk through difficult
one part of it sorry is like naming your
emotions that's something that I went
into this program and I was like wow I
feel like I'm like five years old again
like what are the 10 you know most used
emotions and then what do they actually
do for you and they have like a reason I
don't know all these different things
and so it was kind of just like learning
about being human wow are there any
other tools like the ice one because now
I'm I'm breathing
breathing is one of them different like
breath techniques
um to also slow your heart rate down
another one that I learned Esther was um
to kind of it's it can't not not a full
kill switch like the ice
um thing the ice in your face thing but
when I'm having a severe panic attack is
because it's like a perceived threat
that doesn't actually exist right it's
like this Rush of adrenaline that I
don't know where it's coming from I'm
and now I'm afraid afraid I'm fearing
the fear so it becomes this yes you know
um
um I do this thing where it's like I
look to my left and I look behind me and
I look to my right and I look behind me
and I look all over it's sort of your
body's way of saying look around you
there's actually nothing there and it's
not as effective as the ice thing but it
does work it's one of the the
um the things that I've learned to cope
at least with my panic attacks it and
another one is obviously the the cross
tapping that helps I do like the
this a lot
um I've heard like there's like
something about like trying to stay
grounded of being like this is a chair
identifying yeah five things in a room
touching objects stuff like that but the
ice one I feel like for some reason just
thinking of the feeling of ice water on
my face I can tell that that would like
change my change me yeah they're called
tip skills it's called tip your body
temperature
so there's I think the I the eye must be
the ice no T is for temperature wow can
I remember that it's been like three or
four years
um one of them is oh I is I think
intense exercise so yeah if you like
jump rope really quick or do like
literally yeah jumping jacks or jump
down and do a couple push-ups again it
changes your heart rate so just the
shift in heart rate can kind of calm you
down
um P one of the P's is for paste
breathing and then the other one is
okay so temperature
yeah paste breathing and paste breathing
and
Progressive relaxation I don't know if I
remember that P but yeah
um which is you know in paired muscle
relaxation yeah and that's where you
like squeeze your muscles as hard as you
can if you're like really freaking out
and then you relax them and it like
literally we would just practice this
you would do it for like months and
months so then it becomes second nature
of like when you're actually because
it's one thing to like sit in a class
and learn something but then to actually
go and use it you know that was a hard
part for me is applying it when I'm
already in the crippling anxiety would
have gotten there it's like I don't want
to move a muscle I don't even want to
look any direction but what's in front
of me because I am just so fearful I'm
almost Frozen in fear right so to get
myself to stand up and get ice yeah
that's why you have to practice practice
when you're not in panic so that when
you are in panic you know what to use or
know how to use these skills habitual so
it's like your body knows how to go do
it exactly and so those are some of the
skills like the more behavioral ones and
then a lot of them is just learning how
to navigate like communication and if
you're having like a like interpersonal
issues is kind of one of the big parts
of DBT or what they use to combat it
um and yeah if you're if you want
something from someone how do you ask
them and kind of be oh that's a big one
yeah that's one of them and what like
what so what let's talk about that
that's a big one for you like
um play adult or call
um the call Spectrum because my internet
is down I have to rehearse something in
my I have to say it out loud before the
woman answers because that I fumble and
I don't and I get into this whole Panic
of like talking to a stranger asking
them why my internet's down and then I
it's it's a weird thing that happens
it's like my brain freezes around like
author what I consider a authority
figures in the Spectrum people are
authority figures
in my mind like please don't take away
my TV
I'm not wrong
try to see me at across a bank teller I
like I crumble like can I can I I start
stuttering it's it's a whole thing I
don't know what to ask I freeze this is
making me want to be your husband so I
can like take you through the bank and
be like this is my beautiful lady she
can't do it herself I'll I'll do it you
make me feel useful oh but it's also
yeah it's Crea you have to think of it
also so DBT was originally
invented whatever created for people who
have borderline personality disorder
that was the initial like so it's for
people who struggle with you know
managing their emotions with being a
with interpersonal relationship so
that's kind of what it just like dumbs
it down for you and helps you with the
things that you struggle with do I think
that DBT is helpful for everyone and
anyone yes because once again like this
[ __ ] isn't taught in school and like
when I was 10 years old I wasn't sat
down and said like oh what's the
difference between like jealousy and
envy and what's the difference between
when I'm sad and when I'm angry and how
do I know when it's one but being massed
as the other you know yeah okay so I've
heard you talk a little bit about
borderline on other podcasts you seem to
know more about it like than I do it at
least can you because it's something
that I feel like I'm starting to hear
more of in like our culture and I don't
know exactly what it is like if someone
doesn't know what it is how would you
describe it you know I don't want to
like [ __ ] it up though always makes me
nervous to like say the definitions but
technically it's a personality disorder
what I've learned from going to Mclean
is that it is usually nature nurture
mixed together usually people have a
genetic predisposition like it runs in
their family and then maybe they'll have
a traumatic event that kind of pushes
them over the edge so that's not to say
that if it runs in your family you 100
will always have BPD because that's not
how it works but then sometimes if you
have trauma on top of it you don't
always have to then it can develop and
yeah it is a mental health disorder
um I guess yeah it just causes
functioning issues in your daily life
mostly with like your relationships how
you manage your emotions like there's
nine criteria I believe one of them is
like really like not being able to
control your anger
um another one them another one of them
is like
intense paranoia usually when you're
under a lot of stress
it's got him here for you okay yeah fear
of abandonment
and that's a big one that's one of the
big ones unstable relationships unclear
or shifting self-image so self-image
issues what does that mean
like maybe depending on who you hang out
with you will kind of change your
identity how you dress like you don't
you don't have a strong sense of self
okay yeah another one is self-harm or
like suicidal behavior
um impulsive self-destructive Behavior
such as like shopping addiction spending
a lot of money maybe a lot of drug use
drinking sex it can even show up as like
eating disordered behavior
um extreme emotional swings chronic
feelings of emptiness is usually one of
the big ones do I have this this is I
don't think you do Esther I think I
don't think you do I think you're just
like well I guess you know you have one
emotion emotion yeah I definitely have a
strong sense of self I'm not worried
about that one but I'm like
so usually you meet like six I think of
the nine to be technically diagnosed but
then there's people who like go to the
program I was at and they'll come out of
there and they only meet like three out
of the nine so they're technically they
don't have the diagnosis anymore in
terms of like meeting the criteria but
they still have it it's a lifelong thing
right I would say fear of Abandonment is
just my big one but that kind of feel
like maybe that is kind of fake I feel
like we have more of just anxious
attachment style you and I yeah which
I'm working on anxious attachment I did
you guys watch the Jonah Hill
documentary on Netflix studs when did it
come out it just came out like a couple
weeks ago it's like this it's on his
therapist who's like this great leader
in therapy or whatever it still sucks
yeah and so one of the things that I
real that I learned took away from it
that is a big problem for me is
attachment I'm so attached to like
anything that comes across like
literally meeting you my brain will be
like oh my God I love her I need her in
my life forever like that's just how I
am with everything I I needed all the
time and she's got my name tattooed on
her yeah to tell you enough that's so
true we're just friends
maybe they're lovers when the cameras go
off I'm just kidding that's her
attachments we're not there yeah I'm
learning attachment is my big my biggest
issue but on he talked about it in there
and I was like whoa I could I feel like
just hearing someone offer a solution to
it I'm just like picturing yourself
letting things go and I feel like I'm
definitely on my way to working through
that but I have um when I watch that
documentary how he's like deals with
like visualizing in your mind like some
of some of us aren't that visual in in
my mind like when you tell me like think
of an apple that apple is a very faded
heart like there's no color to the Apple
I'm thinking about and others are able
to really fully visualize an apple in
like a 3D way in their brain so I kind
of wonder if that only works for people
who are able to truly like visualize in
their brain in the same way that some of
us don't have an internal monologue and
some do like I don't hear my internal
monologue it's like very abstract
thoughts in my head and others really do
they hear their voice they hear
everything all of their thoughts so
that's like I think different like I
think that probably works
for some people I can't imagine it like
working for me because it was like
capture yourself on a beach I'm like
I can't get that yeah that sounds like
mindfulness yeah
um
and that's also a part of DVD I know I'm
a big DVT person I'm like always
throwing it out at everyone no that's
cool I because I remember it from my
treatment program like CBT DBT and I
just I I never like remembered what it
was so now they use it for yeah eating
disorder treatment all all depression
anxiety all types of different
illnesses and disorders and whatever it
is so I hit a wall with talk therapy
earlier this year and in the same way
you were saying like hey I can
intellectualize my trauma I can
understand it in and out all upside down
and still feel stuck right so or
sometimes it's also when you're like
harping on all that [ __ ] for so long and
you're like wow I almost just like feel
worse I'm just like talking about how my
life is [ __ ] or I'm not feeling good or
things that happen to me that I can
never change yeah and are out of my
control you're reinforcing it it becomes
even more present as like it's in the
Forefront of your thoughts like I know
that like there are some traumas I kind
of like
choose like not to touch because I'm
like let's not unearth that because I
don't if my brain has done a good job at
sort of like keeping it locked away and
I'm generally like a you know a
functioning adult sometimes I think like
I don't want to like unearth certain
things but earlier this year I was like
talk therapy is just like
thankful it exists thankful I went
through it but I went through a ketamine
session I did ketamine for the first
time like uh with
um a therapist and like a doctor in a
room and I it honestly changed changed
my life yeah
um I've never done ketamine with a
doctor I've done ketamine
with the doctor
um so it's a little bit I'm sure a very
different experience but I've heard good
things about it again like I don't think
it works for everyone right
um and that's what they were saying so
it's like if you have any like
um predisposition to schizophrenia or
any type of like schizoaffective
anything they said that maybe your brain
doesn't have like the centrifugal force
after a ketamine session to sort of
bring your thoughts back together and
sort of like leave it in disarray and
maybe even like trigger you into like
you know an episode an episode yeah do
you do you feel did you fear though any
desire to like want to do it again or
that it would bring up any like
addiction and stuff no because I'm I
think to them how they explained it to
me is like I was a perfect candidate I
don't do drugs I hardly drink I've never
taken ketamine in my life I've never
done any like hardcore anything so I was
sort of like the perfect candidate
candidate of someone being depressed and
like a nervous breakdown and doing it in
like a safe environment right you're
like not an addict no I'm not yeah
that's rare in our business like wow
you're really not an addict it's funny
because I really am not no I in fact I
don't like the feeling of being
um attached to anything like I'm afraid
of you're more avoidant yeah is this why
I'm just so drunk I know wow I can like
see the the magnetic charge between
no it's well that is like I know my mom
is also some like a rare person in my
life from like you are just not an
addict like she just doesn't doesn't get
addicted to things it's so it's like
mind-blowing to me because I'm the
opposite of I'm an addict are you do you
identify as one way or another
definitely not with substances even
though I've literally tried everything
but I've just been I was talking about
this with my therapist literally last
week actually like I even she was like I
don't really think of you as like with
addiction I would say I'm more of an
addict with people I'm a person addict
yeah but I also think that's part of the
BPD a bit so I see yeah does that mean
like like sex and love Anonymous like is
that what no something different no I
mean honestly like when I was kind of
figuring out my mental health Journey
slash diagnosis I thought maybe I was a
sex not a sex addict but more of a lot
yeah and like relationship like I always
needed to be in a relationship since I
was 16 and I could never be alone it was
really hard on me and then when I went
to this program my therapist was like no
that's just borderline like you're not
slaa you don't need that you need DBT
and and this is why I think you know
this is like a brain thing it's not just
that's the symptom is kind of the love
addict if that makes totally yeah like
really Desiring the relationships and
needing someone to fill the void for me
externally is yeah the Band-Aid it's not
what's actually causing that void in the
first place and it's the BPD that is so
interesting because Esther and I have
always labeled ourselves relationship
girls but maybe we can maybe there's
something there that we should dig a
Little Deeper because I'm I can relate
to the fact that I'm always I'm very
uncomfortable when I'm not in a
relationship I'm not a great single
person I'm an even more
I hook up with people like even my three
week little romances feel like love
totally I I I get high on people
I think I do too that's my addiction I
think if you look hard enough most
people are addicts that just may not be
like quintessential it just it may not
be like the quintessential drugs or
alcohol right and also I think people
tend to really overuse this idea of like
being an addict and it's a similar the
way that like a lot of like male comedy
podcasts would be like comedians versus
civilians and I think it's like so dumb
we're all people we're all the same like
normal people are very funny and like
it's just yeah I so I I'm glad that's
coming up again because I take it back
it's like everyone is just a person it
doesn't have to be addict or not addict
that's such a good point though I think
the funniest people in my life are not
comedians no comedians are just people
who are like they have the right [ __ ]
up thing where they think they need to
get on the stage they're great
performers yeah but it doesn't mean that
they're funnier than like the person who
works with the DMV like I'm sorry I
don't think it does mean that like great
I know they'll get mad at me but
[Music]
so if your New Year's goals are to
manage your budget better and save money
you need rocket money say goodbye to
last year's outdated disorganized
methods of managing your money and say
hello to Rocket money the better way to
hack your finances in 2023 rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forgot about like that streaming
service you bought to watch just one
show on our free trial that you never
even used I am so guilty as charged of
all of those like I have so many that
that's that's my lot in life as well
rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones that
you don't want over three million people
have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year I know
for me like my dad always told me like
if you don't know how much money is in
your wallet you'll never be good with
money like and that has always stuck
with me and it's like if you don't know
your money situation how can you ever
really like figure it out you have to
know what you have and know what is
going where so I think just any kind of
like financial literacy is really
important if you if you weren't taught
that or if that's scary to you rocket
money can really be helpful stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday
Eileen I have a question actually yes I
was in AAA for a long time and that's
considered CBT obviously and I hit a
wall where it was just like what you
said a loop of talking about the same
stuff and I heard it for years the same
story over and over again and maybe 10
were lies if not more and I had I had an
experience like Lila where I took
psychedelic meds with a therapist and
everything changed for me and I'm just
wondering if you think that CBT and
Alcoholics Anonymous and things like
that may be outdated I don't think
they're outdated I just think you can
always use more than one thing okay
because I think for me or having sat in
like I've sat in on an AAA not for
myself but I've gone with other people
to support them and I feel like it's so
much about like just getting through
this day just don't use today and then
tomorrow's a new day like it does help
people remain sober but in terms of like
really getting at why you were drawn to
alcohol or drugs or substance in the
first place it doesn't really get at
that meat you know yeah but that's not
the point of it the point is to help you
remain sober
um I think if you think of everything as
a supplement to each other like crazy I
mean we did DB we did CBT too like I I
do talk therapy with my therapist yeah
and I think they can all be used in
conjunction okay
um and I also think it's really
important to like I just did an episode
last week on how to find a therapist and
like my experience with therapy because
I have seen a lot of shitty therapists
and like I have great insurance I have
the money to pay for out of pocket like
I'm so privileged in the grand scheme of
things but at the same time I've also
had a lot of really shitty care um so
I'm like okay then what about the people
who don't have good insurance or you
know don't have the same kind of avenues
that I do
um and I feel like you should interview
a therapist like you would someone
you're gonna date like you don't take a
random person the first person you meet
on the street and you're like hey you're
my part you're my boyfriend or
girlfriend or
um some of us
in our early 20s so like first God asks
sure but really having those
conversations of like okay what kind of
therapy do you do do you do like you
have to look at it as like they work for
you in a way like we're working on me
together yeah we're a team but I
shouldn't be like I don't know I feel
like people will go into those
conversations or a phone call with a new
therapist and they're like too scared to
ask anything they don't want to be rude
you know and that's just things like you
have to once again get better at
practicing but yeah what kind of
patience do you take what kind of
therapy do you do
um have you like this is what I want to
work on do you think you could help me
do you feel like maybe we're not a good
fit could you refer me out to someone
like having those conversations what
kind of therapy like what would be the
right answer for someone like you if you
ask what kind of therapy do you do would
you say like DBT I always say DBT just
because of my diagnosis that's like the
Prime treatment or the prime type of
therapy
um and like for example if you have OCD
or like how your mom is like if she
wanted to get help she should do
exposure therapy or work with an OCD
specialist and another element to that
too is like my mom she is an immigrant
there is a language barrier there is
like a huge like cultural difference
cultural barrier which is like that's
another level of you know trying to like
figure out a match because it has to be
someone who understands their culture
understands like you know for her it's
like seeing a therapist is the ultimate
shame right she comes from a country
that is like you just throw you know
sweep everything under the rug and you
just grin and bear and you White Knuckle
live so it has to be someone who really
understands that so I think it is a very
I love
I love that you're basically giving us
like a blueprint on what questions to
ask because it it simplifies it for
someone who is afraid to go in and kind
of like fumble like an interview because
it is already a very very like you're
going in there at the height a lot of us
are seeking therapy at the height of
like not feeling feeling like [ __ ] right
and now we have to talk to a stranger
and being like are you are you are you
for me are you not for me and it's
uncomfortable to even open up to a
therapist like usually in the beginning
when you're seeing someone new it's
really freaking awkward you're like hey
you don't know me I don't know for a
good match yet and I'm gonna open up
about my life and usually like really
intimate vulnerable details but I think
I just want to reiterate it's not one
size fit all fits all and if someone
doesn't work there's another thousand
people out there and maybe one of them
will so you can't be afraid to like try
someone else and usually I feel like
therapists will kind of give you the
like one session Shin or kind of you
know it's a free phone call it's not
like you have to pay for that and just
interview them yeah you mentioned
exposure therapy and I so it's like all
coming back to me all these words that
like
so that sounds like it could it's like
this like what is that like this crazy
thing but I remember we did that in my
treatment program and it was actually so
simple and the it was so right for me it
was so scary but like it's not scary but
um no it can be really scary it's
essentially just showing you like this
the thing that you fear so if you're
just an example you brought up today is
like your mom with the hangers like
maybe she feels and this is just an
example but like if they're really close
together then like it's out of order
it's gonna [ __ ] up her day
um and so in exposure therapy they would
have her like [ __ ] them all up because
it's showing you like your deepest fear
or what's
giving you paralyzing fear in this
moment isn't gonna kill you yeah so like
a great example is literally what they
have an OCD clinic at McLean Hospital
the hospital I went to I wasn't in that
program but it's like one of the best
ones it's called ocdi
um and if someone comes to them with
like extreme Arachnophobia this is the
example I always give they'll start by
like looking at a photo for like one
second like you're scrolling through
Instagram and then like maybe a spider
pops up and it's just to go through it
but they'll work with them and okay
maybe that like makes them want to
scream or cry or run across the room but
they'll slowly keep showing them that
okay it's just on the screen it's not
going to kill you and then they get to
the point where they literally bring in
a live tarantula and they let it walk on
their face that's like the when you
graduate the program kind of do they
have this for cockroaches yeah I mean
they have everything and anything that's
like a very that's for cockroaches
that's a very like specific
visual example but then there's a lot of
like internal pure oh or like just
obsessions that don't have a compulsion
attached or a behavior attached to it
for my exposure therapy which to it like
still makes me so uncomfortable to think
about but it was literally and you will
laugh at this it's so stupid but it was
like we all had to have our like trigger
foods like foods that you would like
really want to overeat on and so like we
would all we all it was like watching a
movie day we went and watched a movie in
the basement and
um I had like a really small bowl like
serving size of Sour Patch watermelon
and like a single serving of popcorn and
I was like
I hate like I hated it I just hated the
thought of having like my two favorite
things and just having only a small
amount but like having that experience
it was so valuable to me to be like oh
this is possible I was it's possible it
happened I mean it shows it literally
like TR shows your brain that like when
it gets triggered it can still get
through it
and like your body it's it's really
amazing but it's really difficult and
like a lot of like I commend anyone who
goes through any type of exposure
therapy I think it's the hardest type of
therapy
um I mean you're literally like facing
your fears
and
yeah I mean I've seen people get like
really emotional it's really really
difficult work yeah but it does change
your life like if there's one takeaway
from this episode it's like going away
or even doing therapy changed my life
like I am a completely different person
than I was three years ago in the best
way too that's how I feel about my
treatment which was literally just for
binge eating and like I feel like it it
helped everything else in my life also
because I know you mentioned like
it's harder for the older Generations
like therapy is so stigmatized they
think like that's for crazy people
I
I was so blown I was went home for
Thanksgiving and I heard my dad say
postpartum depression that's when the
woman wants to kill the baby right and I
was like it almost it blew me away
because it was so comical to me but I'm
like that is what he thinks I remember
when I thought that's what it was but
like postpartum depression is like just
being sad it's just depression after
pregnancy it doesn't mean you wanted to
kill your baby necessarily but it's so I
also don't think that postpartum is the
is is like the
the underlying like that's more killing
killing your baby is like a Band-Aid
weird solution and like a crazy case of
it yeah but it's it's just like they
people don't really know about mental
health and it's kind of surprising I
mean it doesn't surprise me and that's
sad but but it's just like no one talks
about it yeah they don't teach it in
schools yeah also why what flip side
though yeah because we are starting to
talk about mental health what are your
thoughts on people
um I mean I have to pee sorry I'll pay
you soon no no we can't let me answer
this what are your thoughts on people
just willy-nilly diagnosing people oh
like on Tick Tock and stuff too
um
um diagnoses are just like
insane no I I think you need to go to a
real professional and I think of that
even with like therapy too like oh sorry
part of my episode about finding a
therapist was like I prefer finding a
therapist who's part of a larger
organization so whether that's a
hospital or a university
um and then a lot of the times they'll
work in tandem with other people kind of
in their programs so you have more than
one like you have more eyes on your case
exactly and that makes a huge difference
um
yeah I mean there are just a lot of
people who
are not
like they they don't have the
credentials to back it up but yes like
everyone's a narcissist everyone is uh
yeah and that's a really overused term
that's always wrong like everything I
see online is wrong about it wait I feel
like I recently came across this too
like I just read somewhere that like
literally every human being is a
narcissist like okay so there's healthy
narcissism and then there's narcissism
that is like
oh [ __ ] what's the word
um that's gonna bother me um oh I'm
hungry I'm down from wait no do I have
to do something weird
[Music]
for now it's just a potassium re-up in
the same way that um ice to the face
potassium to the heart is good okay yeah
that's all this is sorry I'm wait this
the mic's on right yeah oh I was gonna
say sorry I feel like sometimes I'm such
a not a boring guest but I just like I'm
not the most charismatic person I mean I
literally made a career out of being
depressed
I'm not even kidding that like is my
career people will always be like oh
you're not a therapist like I'll get
these messages like that or like what
makes you feel like you have the
credentials to talk about this stuff and
I'm like no no I'm not pretending to be
a therapist over here I'm just talking
about my own experience of like being
mentally messed up I love that wait I'm
so confused you've been engaged actually
for five years so yeah wait wait can can
you just tell Eileen um when Dave how
long ago Dave had his bachelor party
Dave my fiancee does he listen to this
podcast yes it's gonna hurt his feelings
no what no why would it hurt us I don't
know no we're gonna hit it why why
wouldn't it
we no so we got engaged his bachelor
party was
definitely at least four years ago now
uh
uh who's getting cold feet here no one
is getting Cold's feet we are actually
at a weird like
we're at a standstill where where we're
still negotiating the terms of our
wedding which is basically he wants to
have a wedding with family okay and I
want to elope I that's I just wedding
culture is like why can't you do a mix
oh man I'm such a problem it's crazy I'm
like okay you do the you elope for the
actual wedding you have a little weekend
away with you guys and then when you
come home or you do you like a week
honeymoon somewhere fun and then you
come back and you get like a wedding
party with your family and friends
because that's really important to him
that's that's interesting
I also think that like growing up my
parents literally got married in a
courthouse and had no wedding and so to
me like what and I'm not religious I
just have no attachment to marriage
culture wedding culture man I'm so the
opposite it's scary why I know and
people like I feel like with my whole
online Persona or everything that I do
and talk about they that's shocking for
them oh my gosh if you ask my friends I
have a presentation of what my wedding
looks like I make I make my friends
they've all seen my presentation be
presented to them it's always though
like I know exactly where my wedding is
I know what I want to wear la la it's
the only thing that plug in husband TBD
does it change though no so it's been a
fixed thing this is how I want yes will
you tell us a little bit about this plan
I feel like I can't okay because that's
okay I know I'm just kidding no I do
present it though to people but yeah I
mean I want to get married at a very
specific place in France like I know
it's and I want a time a small wedding
like maybe like 30 people is fine that's
a letter to micro wedding yeah yeah like
maybe 40 depending on like again who I
marry and like how many people he wants
to bring but like
sorry to my cousins like no cousins it's
like my siblings I obviously I want them
there and my friends but that's pretty
much it but you sort of eliminate the
stress of having to invite a whole lot
of family when you do destination
wedding anyways right yeah or I think a
lot of people just like you invite them
and they can't come which you kind of
expect but I just want yeah a tiny a
small wedding with really good food I
want pink peonies is my favorite flower
I these are really pretty yeah and I
just want it to be like a chill I want
it to be with people I have an emotional
connection with like I've gone to
weddings or even Thanksgiving this year
with my extended family and I'm like wow
you guys are all strangers but we're
blood related so I've been sitting in
this room with you and it feels really
awkward and I had such bad social
anxiety this year that I got really
drunk and
that's not what I want at my wedding I
want to know that like everyone's here
and they really know me for me and
they're like happy for my love and they
want to celebrate this moment with me
and that's what I want because that is a
specific kind of trauma like having to
um get so this forced
um
um love with family that I've had to
deal with like especially in like
Filipinos right I've had to spend so
many Christmases with the person that
diddled me because it's Christmas like
you know um everybody like you know
every this is a truce
um everyone is invited and I have to sit
there and eat my freaking you know what
I mean like spiral ham while looking at
the guy that like diddled me and
everyone's like here he got you a gift
and I'm like thanks and you know and but
it's like the expectation to just like
lay out yeah lay down your defenses like
it's Christmas time and now you're
forced into this room with your
murderous uncle and the [ __ ] you know
little King and you're just like okay
you know I guess so I love that I love
that it's like you know that's just like
also a boundary that I I feel like maybe
five six years ago wouldn't know how to
uphold and now I like that is something
that's really important to me like even
at Thanksgiving this year it was so
awkward and I'm not super close with my
dad's family that I told him I was like
next year you know I don't really know
if I want to go to that Thanksgiving and
my dad's supportive and he was like
that's fine like you don't have to if
you don't want to you can do something
else
um boundaries I am 34 and I can't
believe I literally learned about them
like this year like it's crazy and then
again it's like practicing because like
when you you know we can talk about
boundaries all we want and like I could
Journal about what my boundaries are but
then I come into like a Heat of the
Moment thing and they all disappear like
I don't know how to withhold that I
don't know how to tell someone like hey
that made me uncomfortable in the heat
at the moment when you feel awkward or
anxious so it's like practice practice
tell people your boundaries too like
close friends so I feel like in moments
if they're with you they can also help
you uphold them if that makes sense yes
oh my God clylla we need to practice
that I need you need to help me yeah or
you know because if you're out and
you're like drinking you're at a bar and
like maybe you told your friend like hey
I have this boundary recently we're like
I really I want to take some time for
myself and I don't want to hook up with
anyone and then you're like a couple
drinks in and you're like oh this guy's
flirting with me let me go for this like
external quick validation and your
friend could be like hey hold on a
minute we have this conversation today
is this really what you want to do oh I
I feel like that's the role that I would
like excel at like you're helping me I
really can like I would love to be your
little boundary coach like I'm a
babysitter like I have such sidekick
energy low-key like I feel like I would
love to do that I would love to be that
role for people I'll I'll let I'll be so
sure I have a situation under control
and then walk out of there being like Oh
I let that person trample all over I
know right and then just or it's like
wow the bar was so low
well I feel like we're a good option
like we're a good pair because for me I
would I feel like you have a hard time
like saying no and and for me I'm like a
come on let's like oh I love you let's
do this and so it like we're we're a
potentially toxic combo of that but with
the awareness we could really like
exercise with each other like I think
that's a really good point you're making
because I can I can firmly say no on
behalf of somebody else but not for
myself like when Bobby Bobby my
ex-partner used to have a lot of trouble
um telling people no like hey let me
open for you on the road or let me do
this he would always say talk to Kal
Island I was the person who could say no
for him I cannot say no for myself that
maybe you can be that person for me yeah
wait that's actually so amazing it's
also like to help help but it's helping
you practice to be able to do it
yourself and one day because you know
they're not always going to be there to
like save you in that moment right
oh Esther will be there
wondering she doesn't let let the phone
ring
wondering she's there
um and even for our other our co-host
Annie who's not here today like when she
told me that she wanted to quit smoking
cigarettes like I was the best moment of
my life because I didn't even know she'd
smoke cigarettes but I was like I got
you like she's I made her send me this
long text of why she wanted to I feel
like here's the contrast yeah
fully and like she every time you smoke
one you put ten dollars in my piggy bank
yes like I'm so good at keeping that
keeping other people in line that's
really weird
um but although back to wedding I will
say I have one detail of two details of
my wedding
if there is one planned which is one my
friend roomie Neely is gonna design the
dress and she's like she her brand is
are you in mind it's all this like hot
super hot girl clothes so I'm like
excited that his motivation he just sent
me a ton of stuff over the weekend
really and I never thought that I would
look good in any of this stuff but I put
it on I'm like and I I honestly I look
so [ __ ] hot I need photos that's so
unfair I need photos of Esther you would
die you would eat me out so fast
this is when we put it in the YouTube
video it pops up for your selfie your
mirror pet I'll send it to you thank you
and then I also know that I want to have
really dramatic vows
I really want to have like vows that
make everyone uncomfortable even though
in my fantasy also no one will be there
but I mean is this just like just to get
under Dave's skin and be performative or
a little bit yeah yeah yeah because you
ordered Princess Diana Let Me Dance For
You Charles yes yes yeah he already said
that like he needs to have one of his
friends proofread my vows because he
doesn't trust me
so throw in some jokes yeah yeah like
Mike sure will be punching at my wedding
vows
um
but okay yeah those are my two wedding
things that I at least but we'll see I
don't know it may never happen Pastor
that's like that just sounds like a
threat
like poor Dave he's like well okay I'm
gonna elope because I don't want her to
leave me no we're not that's it do you
guys live together yeah we live together
they're the best like they are amazing
because I don't want to live with my
person before we get married you you
don't I know and everyone thinks I'm
crazy I know I'm actually I get that I
have like super well actually this is
hilarious so my ex-boyfriend and I I
didn't want to marry him at the time but
we always joke like oh if we break up
like when I'm older and around the age
that I do want to get married like we
can get back together and get married
and I was like but I but if we start
dating again I don't want to have sex
until we get married even though we've
had sex obviously and he was like that's
a really good way to get cheated on oh
[ __ ] that's not what I was gonna say
that's like a good way to get it no but
he's like no but no but he was like What
if you're engaged and you have and you
have to plan
for like eight months or six months and
to not have sex if you had been having
sex like he was giving me his honest
opinion he wasn't trying to be crass
yeah and I was like okay that's fair I
didn't think about it like that I didn't
see that idea of like
but then is that like weird puritanical
like probably some like internal
misogyny that I have and a lot of
internal sexism going on over here maybe
I don't want to live together and like
maybe I don't want to [ __ ] while we're
like planning the wedding so we have
something to like look forward to the
night of I don't know I think but it
could all change this is me right now
things are constantly maybe you just
find it hot and like for me that sounds
hot like oh we're gonna wait it out and
I'm gonna be so [ __ ] come dumb at our
wedding ah I'm so turned on by that idea
I'm gonna withhold I think if I told
Dave that we're not gonna have sex to
our wedding I think I think he would
finally hit me
I think he would just hit me he'd be
like no [ __ ] like we're not really I'm
into that you are yeah something about
the edging that Oh I thought you meant
the hitting her
hitting you not that it's funny to laugh
at Dave hitting me but it kind of is you
would like it you did hit it married
immediately he did hit her a couple
weeks ago you were going to hit Annie
you I don't know if you threw a banana
and you accidentally hit us there strike
we don't have to call the police I threw
a bunch of stuff including a gun wait
I'm confused you're not engaged no no I
would Annie the girl that sits there
yeah yeah okay the writer or whatever I
threw a bunch of stuff at her because I
was angry I acted out I need DBT and
um and Esther got in the way and she was
trying to get out of the line of fire
got hit what did you throw a banana
banana these trash cans no yeah me and
your dad are settling out of court no he
didn't tell me
Carlos's dad is a is a um a doctor he's
a lucrative surgeon oh so so Esther and
him plastic no no oncology yeah
important stuff important stuff yeah
yeah
um I want to ask you guys I saw this
thing on Tick Tock about
um men losing their not losing but
having sex for the first time with um
what is it Carlos well it's not for the
first time that they're having sex it's
just that men like escorts who are older
like oh I understood that differently
okay young guys love the Secret Lives of
older sex workers oh wait so I've
actually but my last episode was called
my I'm in my cradle robbing era
I've been exclusively hooking up with
younger guys wait really yeah yeah they
are no no
um but I yeah I did an episode on that
and
I have faced so much backlash and
judgment that's true what it's like
but I actually have like some so my
friends will give me so much [ __ ] and I
just feel like there's a lot of
yeah there's a lot of sexism I feel like
it's so normalized for men to date
younger girls or [ __ ] younger girls and
it's like they're almost like put on a
pedestal when they do it but then if a
girl does it it's kind of like looked
down upon me what is that experience
like because I have to say the thought
of younger guys is so unappealing to me
in fact like I think I'm the only woman
on earth who is completely immune to
being attracted to Pete Davidson simply
because I met him when he was so young
that I'm like ew he's just a little kid
to me like I don't get it how like what
is your experience been with younger
guys do they even know how to do it I
mean actually okay no I mean yeah some
of them do not at all and then some of
them have but I think there's a mix
thing so for me background I am not
emotionally available right now I don't
want to be in a relationship I feel very
scarred from my last like serious
breakup I was in like an on and off
thing with my ex-boyfriend for years
like it was a serious relationship that
kind of turned into a situationship and
I just feel really exhausted from that
experience and just not in a place where
I'm ready to like
yeah be emotionally there for anyone or
get hurt or commit or be vulnerable I
love hearing you say that I love I've
never really heard someone be like oh so
here's the deal I'm not emotionally
built right now here's why like that's
so mature I used to say it more
eloquently than me I'm
what I've been telling people
80 is my Max you're gonna get 80 and
that's it like no I feel like I'm even
lower but I but at the same time I am
like a little bit of like we talked
about in addict for
people right I'm addicted to people so I
think it's this perfect mix of like a
younger guy is not really going to
expect me to date them and for the most
part I feel like they tend to be like
pretty obsessed with you they have like
a amazing sex drive because they're like
horny all the time and and I also like
have no problem teaching someone what to
do so it's just been kind of fun but I
think it's more of like I feel protected
and that this is never going to become
anything and I almost grouped them in
of like I don't take it too seriously
right it's just fun you're my toy boy
right it's what you need right now
yeah yeah I think that sounds perfectly
fine so I'm in my cougar era yeah yeah
oh my God fun the what like the very few
times I like sort of like was hanging
out with like young dumb a younger
Dumber guy I remember like we were on a
walk and he'd be like
do you think I could I could hit that
sign from here it was like no no no no
no I definitely
I'm not even kidding I have those
moments though where I'm like please
just don't open your mouth yeah oh
seriously and that's something like I've
had to just
you know I am
kind of accepting of those things to get
the other things of what it what and and
think to myself like what is this
providing me and actually like this guy
that I've been seeing just ended things
with me because he was like I really
want a relationship and I want something
more and I know that that's not what you
want slash like you don't really see
anything beyond kind of what this is and
that's not what I want and like I don't
want to get hurt so we ended things and
I was like okay I mean
I thank you for your service yeah thank
you for your service and on to the next
here's your purple heart yeah yeah I
mean at least he was honest and like he
could communicate that with me yeah and
what a great like for young men at least
what great practice it is to have
healthy sexual relationship with a girl
yeah like boundaries and like sober a
lot of the time and like hang out and
just like really comfortable learning
how to break things off the right way
like everything I I think that's almost
like honestly you're doing God's work
that's charitable yeah that is that is
right I know but it's hard to also not
like I'm a human and I definitely like
[ __ ] my life up all the time and have an
ego so it's hard to not like you know in
my right mind when I'm feeling great I
can be like okay we'll let it let it
just dissipate and like we can remain
friends or be friendly but then I'll
have other moments where I'm like [ __ ]
you right so it's like it's a learning
experience for me too to not be so
attached like I feel like I always was
always in these super serious
almost love bombing relationships and
then they would Crash and Burn and I
would jump right into the next one and
this is the first time in my life this
last year that I've been single after
that horrible breakup that I'm just kind
of like okay I don't feel single
necessarily because I am seeing people
like I'm never alone but I don't have
like a boyfriend or someone that I'm
like committed to right I kind of want
to defend like
not liking being single like I don't
think there's anything wrong with that I
I think both being single and being in a
relationship like they shouldn't be
at odds with each other it shouldn't be
like
but
that's that's to say
um you can be in a healthy yeah exactly
because I feel like you need to know
yourself and love yourself before you
can be in a relationship or else you're
bringing like you know this person into
my life to fill a void that has nothing
to do with them yeah and I feel like
that's what I did for years and years
like I would date people and settle in
relationships where I was like I [ __ ]
hate this guy like I have nothing in
common with him if I wasn't so miserable
and empty feeling like I would never
date this person I'm I don't think
they're interesting yeah I did that for
years but I'm like I don't want to be
alone and it's someone who it's like a
warm body they can come lay next to me
we have sex maybe they're like obsessed
with me we go to dinner we like hang out
and go on vacation together it's just
basically like cuffing season but all
year yeah that's what I would do for
years and I always felt like I'm like
wow I feel even more alone and I'm with
someone right that's something because
relationship with my mom because you
don't know me for me right yeah and I
like we're not going to skip over that
I'm like you're obsessed with me like
it's kind of like being alone like I
really relate to that I really did I had
a meltdown yesterday with my mom and um
I wasn't in
the family forgot to invite me to my
favorite Korean restaurant which they
all went to and they knew I was alone at
home hungry how do they forget that's
what I'm sorry I'm not believing that
story
um so they might have told you that
story I'm confused so they were all
supposed to go to the Americana in
Glendale and they were like do you want
to come and I said no I don't but they
changed they changed their plan to my
favorite Korean spot but then they
didn't invite me they were like we
already invited you Americana you didn't
want to hang I was like that's not the
point I introduced you guys to sunung
Dan you need to invite me to sunundan
okay I kind of get their point of view
yeah they're like she already flaked and
like didn't care about the plans right
just because of the restaurant she
didn't want to hang out with us so then
why should she come to right so my mom I
only found this out yesterday they were
like oh yeah wait it's sitting down last
night I'm like what what do you mean and
then I started to raise my voice I was
like listen like I'm hurt like my
feelings are hurt and my mom is so old
school she doesn't know what like her
feelings are
so like get the [ __ ] up he's like she's
like what do you mean and so it turned
into this whole fight where I'm like I
just need you to acknowledge that
something like that would hurt my
feelings
and she doubled down and now she is
stonewalling me and giving me the cold
shoulder and won't speak to me because I
raise my voice because my feelings were
hurt and so I know this is so dumb but
like this is their relationship with my
mom currently or like when you're like
I'm I feel like she's always there but I
always feel alone somehow yeah like
that's it where I'm like can you just
accept that I can have these feelings
she's like no you're not allowed to have
those feelings because that is a dumb
feeling to have
to feel like angry over sunung Dan
that's that's very similar to my dad my
dad like when I I had a sort of a life
breakdown like right before covid and
when I flew home to see my parents
because I thought that was gonna help
um I was crying hysterically as I got
into the car and my dad just looks at me
like stop crying you're not sad and I'm
like like this is why I have problems
like will not acknowledge I don't know
yeah no acknowledgment of feelings but
then you have to I don't know I feel
like I've got gathered so much more
empathy and understanding of my dad
totally because I'm like wow you are
like you didn't grow up with this
communication around emotions or
feelings like if I thought I was stunted
you're like a hundred times a hundred
feet behind me just in terms of like
those years and societally and I think
that's part of growing up too right is
like meeting people where they're at
like I can look at my mom with like
utmost empathy even though I did yell at
her yesterday but I could look at her
with empathy and being like I'm gonna
meet you where you're at and she I I am
stunted but like you said like she was
stunted she was not given I know and
it's like also trying to change someone
in their 60s or 70s or however old is
very different than like in their 20s or
30s oh man I that makes a lot of sense
because I am been I've been trying to
change my parents and my dad is 79 and
I'm like is this what I should just kind
of call her medical acceptance yeah
that's a part of DBT to accept where
your life is that you cannot change the
things that have happened to you I mean
it's kind of like the AAA thing the AAA
little right except the things you
cannot change wait Carlos um so you um
had sex for the first time with an older
woman yeah recently no I'm 35 now you
had sex for the first time
I had sex for the first time on the
cried 20th birthday
in Marina del Rey with an escort
how was that can I ask for who set this
up for you how did you find her I found
her myself online
um it was a lot of fun actually and she
didn't know I was losing my virginity so
it's like this secret I had we had a
good time and yeah how much older was
she
I think she might have been like 16 17
years older than me okay yes and overall
you felt like you had a good experience
yeah I mean I did it a million times
after that so yeah
yeah but like
that relationship towards women was
definitely like altered dude though
definitely I didn't go to college for
more than a year so like I always think
like I didn't I was sober too so I
didn't go to parties or out in L.A or
anything like that so getting girls I
was just like well I can't get girls
because I'm 20 in the second largest
city in America so I'm just gonna buy
them
and I just did that until I felt like I
could get a girlfriend basically and
when you did finally get a girlfriend
um were there any sort of like there
isn't is there issues at first what do
you mean when I had my first girlfriend
in La it was so different than being
with an escort obviously that I had to
like adjust what like sex was to me I
was like oh this isn't like a
transaction because I'm bored or
whatever or because there's no like
basketball on tonight like this is like
a loving right you can't just say show
up and [ __ ] there's actually like
there's foreplay there's like setting
them up setting up yeah yeah I had to
learn but I also think that this may
sound crazy but seeing escorts helped me
like
like I never got canceled or anything
because I was with these girls and I was
like nice to them because they were all
basically older than me yeah you always
ate them out too yes you do know that
part about me too I love that well I I
feel like okay
I I want to try to articulate this for
you because you've said this and I think
it's it is kind of interesting like
like you were because you would pay a
sex worker for sex you didn't feel like
you had to like
bully girls into sleeping with you which
is like what other like gross men and
will do and so I do think they're that's
pretty never cared about getting laid at
a bar or anything like I remember being
with like Benji at a bar and like there
were girls and I was like I don't care
about these girls at all they're all
like assistance at agencies and [ __ ]
like I don't give a [ __ ] about them
because I'm gonna go have sex with an
escort in Westwood in an hour and she's
like a supermodel and I will I don't
have to deal with it an hour later like
this is a little problematic do you ever
feel like any weird like guilt of like
why are they in the situation
um I feel like I have had that before
and that's why like me seeing escorts
has definitely decreased
um but my best experiences were with
girls who were more just like
like us here they were just they were
like only fans girls before they were
there was only fans basically
um yeah what are your thoughts on this I
because like Carlos I do feel like it
comes off a little problematic well I'll
say this that's okay as somebody who is
in a 10-year relationship with a a guy
who would regularly you know pay sex
workers right it does while you guys
were in the relationship no no before
okay but like serially like that was
something that he just did regularly was
pay for sex
um it has it's I I can feel it I can
feel that there is almost like a lack of
learning how to be present sexually in a
way that I needed him to be because he's
used to sort of just being like yeah
there's more trains yeah so it was hard
for him to understand the idea of like
touching my shoulder or sweet talking me
and kind of like you know like setting
the build or the build up and then you
showing someone also that you care it's
not just purely sexual right right or
even having sex outside of the goal of
just coming you know just being close
and like intimate in bed all of those
things were really really difficult for
him
um and I felt that very strongly and
it's one of the reasons like that you
know ultimately our relationship didn't
work because then he defaulted to
um just watching porn every day because
it was just you know a quick come he
didn't have to put in the work for me
and he could get his nut off every night
as opposed to
you know the effort it would take to get
my engine going you know what I mean
yeah sex almost seems like chore maybe
not a chore like it could be separate
from a relationship which sounds like
really bad but like
I
it feels like I don't this sounds so
dumb like I'm tooting my own horn but I
don't need to use women for sex because
there are a million escorts out there
and I can just be friends with women and
have a good time and not have all that
drama or it like clouding my brain and
I'm stressed out like I see all my
friends but I think what you're missing
out on is like intimacy no not even love
it doesn't have to be love or just the
intimacy of like having a sexual moment
with someone that perhaps you don't feel
in those more transactional moments um
right although it is worth noting he was
married so he probably had that in your
marriage right yeah I felt like I had a
good sex life in my marriage for sure
and I thought that that would like
change me in my relationship towards
women but I'm divorced now
like I'm divorcing back on the market
I'm sure there's just pros and cons I
mean I've had people on my podcast who
are like very Pro sex work and inactive
are active sex workers and then I've had
ex-sex workers who are like very very
against it and their view is that people
are if they didn't have to be they
wouldn't be a part of that world because
it's very dark and so it's it's almost
always if you dig a Little Deeper for
you know kind of financial reasons and
um I always tip
sweet man Carlos thank you
um and so that's kind of where it's
[ __ ] up okay
yeah it's interesting I
I feel like I
I
see I see both sides like I do respect
Carlos that he does he sex workers but I
also see why it's problematic
um yeah it's kind of like how as a
consumer then like let's say you know
I'm a man looking for
um
transactional sex how do I discern who
is in it for like because I mean we have
friends who are in the industry both who
are porn girls who have been successful
porn girls for a long time like for
instance I always use her as an example
is asakira Right grew up in New York
really good
um upbringing went to private school but
just found herself super like
hypersexual at a very young age yeah
that's like Stella Berry too yeah like
Stella Berry she wanted to Parlay that
into this you know thing right yeah um
so like if I'm a man like
like is it is the responsibility on me
then to choose or find a sex worker who
truly is like
in it for the job like wants to do this
there are signs like they're more
expensive or they don't have Russian
accents those are my two I think this
this ex prostitute and that's what she
likes to call herself okay mommy podcast
um tweaked about she uses the word
prostitute she likes that word yeah
because she's like there's so many
different types of sex work and she was
like that is what I did I was a
prostitute and like that is the term I
wasn't a cam girl so she was like that
is what I like to use
um but she really talks about how she
feels like it's exploiting low-income
women or it's people who are in kind of
but yeah Financial situations where they
have to be doing that and they wouldn't
be doing it otherwise so it's kind of
like exploiting that system but isn't it
interesting that is like
to me that's like you could just look at
our culture for that one like I would
blame our culture for why women are in
that situation I don't know I'm this is
over my head but I will I think the
positive of it is like
I'd rather see a guy
see a sex worker than like
beg me to [ __ ] him you know like the
guys that you've hung out with who are
aggressively trying to [ __ ] you or like
you don't want to have sex with them and
it's like do you know what I'm saying
like or could they just change their
behavior yeah why put that on to a sex
worker though yeah because I feel like
that same energy that you hate in them
now will be put onto another woman and a
woman who's like getting paid so she has
to shut up about it
interesting and like why are certain
women you know like why is there a totem
pole of like some people are at the
bottom of the totem pole and then other
people are at the top and usually it
comes down to like Financial privilege
or socioeconomic privilege
yeah you know like I'm like like I'm not
in a situation where I have to
you know be do sex work to like pay my
bills for example I have a lot of
different opportunities but there's some
people that would come before that and
then there's many people who don't feel
like they have opportunities before that
um
so it's it's it's it's a lot more
nuanced because basically you have the
Stella berries right who are like wait
she comes from a family who's you know
her mom is a doctor right she was in
school she was going to school at what
is it she's Essie or she was in college
trying to be a doctor or NYU yeah she's
only like the most expensive right so
you have the Stella berries which is the
best case scenario yeah that is it's on
her terms she [ __ ] who she wants to
[ __ ] to make a video most of the time
it's just with her boyfriend and she
does it from like the privacy of her own
or like the luxury whatever of her own
home and then uploads it and she's like
beautiful she's really skinny she's
white she has all these things kind of
working with her to make her only fan so
big you know but the struggle is not the
same for somebody who is a sex worker
and like she says at the bottom of the
totem pole so like having to walk down
Culver I don't know yeah I'm naming
Street I don't know yeah it's crazy how
privileged it works in your favor even
in sex work so that is true but can't I
see the positive in
the potentially positive versions of it
do you know what I'm saying yeah are
there positives I feel like there are
like I don't know
I get them I'm not anti-sex work I think
that there's just a lot more like you
know you cannot just be so pro-sex work
that you're blind to the idea of
privilege and a different totally yeah
totally yes of course but also I'm like
in this conversation like no one here is
donated snoring so loud no one is gonna
like solve the issue in our culture that
like women are [ __ ] so [ __ ] over
and they're like have no money and
they're in these terrible situations
like that's I'm I'm not gonna solve that
today but like I still want to be able
to say that
there are positive instances of it right
or do you not what do you think I know I
think it depends honestly like a lot of
my opinions change when I had this woman
Esperanza on but she also just talked
about like the rates of people getting
arrested like most of the time John's
don't get in trouble they walk away with
a slap on the wrist and then a woman
who's in like more of a dire situation
she's the one that goes to jail and then
she can't pay her bail and it's like you
just look at the system of a hole there
is a lot of [ __ ] upness yeah no I I
know can I just say I pay bail for a
girl like five years ago in Orange
County she was really sweet
and I just want to put that out there
You're a Good Samaritan Carlo you're not
on the back foot here
um but yeah yeah when and also don't you
think it's a little bit like treating
women like objects
you're like paying for a hole kind of
but then I've also had people who are
always paid for yeah I've had people who
are like oh [ __ ] I forget the term it's
like surrogacy for people who like let's
say if you were 40 years old and a
virgin you would pay someone to kind of
walk you through that experience or for
someone who's like maybe in a wheel in a
wheelchair or something they'll have sex
with you and it's kind of or they're
called intimacy surrogates I kind of
okay so this is a really interesting
topic to me because
um
I have this idea in my head about being
in like a long distance relationship
with somebody and not seeing being able
to see him maybe sometimes for like a
month or like a month and a half and I
don't think I would be opposed to like a
surrogate sort of like
somebody that he both liked that was
like a trusted person in our life to
just sort of like
have sex with him while I'm away or is
that
I mean is that am I just a cuck no I'm
like if that could work for you like
listen I say this about open
relationships or polyamory all the time
I'm like if it can work for you that's
awesome I know myself it would never
work for me
hmm I'm too jealous like I to me sex
it's difficult for
me sometimes to separate like sex and
love so I imagine other people even
though I know people can totally have an
opposite experience to that
um and so I think that would be hard for
me to separate if I knew that they were
ongoing having this thing right but if
it was more like hey it's like twice a
week Tuesdays and Thursdays like you
know we get together this is obviously
not someone I'm picking out at random
like don't you think you're playing a
fire a little bit absolutely but if
they're like what if they're like oh I
still want to do this when you're back
or they're like hey let's have a
threesome like I'm intimate with both of
you but I'd probably be open to that
okay
um but again you're right I mean I'm I
mean you have to be really just like
confident and secure with yourself to do
that and if you are then yeah I think
like this is where we're we're like old
old ladies and you're like not
like because I because I also I'm like I
remember a time where I would react
exactly like that but maybe it's just
like spending a year doing a podcast
with kalila I'm like okay like let's
just hear this like let's see where
you're going it's also more of like a
I'm tired I got [ __ ] to do and we're
also a part but also it's like I
um yeah I'd say it doesn't threaten my
being in a way that it once did and it
just seems very like something that's
more of like functional than than
emotional yeah
um but I don't know like who would you
even choose like what is the criteria
for that because it you are still what
if she falls in love with her right
right because if I'm choosing that guy
like he's got he's a great guy he's very
choosable he's very choosing yeah but I
also think oh my something my therapist
has been telling me like non-stop which
I feel like pertains to the situation is
like even if if
they get feelings for each other
whatever it's not a replacement for you
because you his relationship with her
will never be his relationship with you
because it's not you so like just being
secure enough in that I think is kind of
like okay take it as it may
yeah I like that advice
that's I can apply that to all my
ex-boyfriends no thank you one of my
favorite things you ever screamed at me
across a table of 50 people was kalila
will you have sex with Dave or fiance
what was the circumstance
I think I was being silly but also like
I do feel like when you're in a when
it's 10 years together and it's like
people you trust it's like I could see a
world where kalila is sexually involved
with and then Jenna was like I'll do it
and you were like you were like not you
I don't ask you
Jenna wouldn't be like as premium of an
experience oh no I'm gonna hear that
she's fine
um okay I'm trying to like think of any
other well what is your oh my gosh I
can't so cute do you I'm just curious
just based on like everything so far
what your relationship with or opinion
of porn is because I haven't watched
porn this morning okay okay
so you don't you're not like against
porn
I don't know I mean no I'm not against
porn I think when you relate it to sex
work and
yeah then I'm like okay what's the
difference between the two and
do I think porn has a lot of negative
consequence do I watch porn yeah
absolutely do I feel like it has
negative consequences for like how
people talk to women treat women view
women on like a larger scale absolutely
I think we would be silly to ignore that
yeah especially with like younger people
and younger men just like
also the effect on like porn is a lot of
people's sex education yeah and like
they don't use condoms and like they
don't show people getting tested and
um
and I think there's a lot of derogatory
like really freaky [ __ ] on the internet
and so you have to take it with a grain
of salt yeah it's not so nothing's black
and white yeah
I get tested at this place called
Cutting Edge testing and that's where
all the porn girls go and they all sign
I mean they're all tested to work in as
a serious porn star like doing videos
for like a legit company
um they're getting tested literally like
before you go to any set you're tested
right I mean everyone's name is on there
and in fact when you get tested you can
choose a package and there's a
performer's package
oh my God I want that it's very
normalized and it's great yeah but one a
one even higher up than that that I get
then that tests for both
um
um both herpes one and herpes two which
is not part of like the other packages
this should be the John package
our friend John or like yeah
but it's like yeah they don't show
because it's entertainment it was never
meant to be sex education so it's like
they don't talk about anything and
there's no like warming up or foreplay
and porn usually like it's it's really
not about the female pleasure in porn
right so I think that's maybe the type
of porn that I watch is very geared
towards the girl only receiving pleasure
and not the guy like if I see any
[ __ ] I'm out like and I think this
is why I watch nine percent of porn is
gonna be the other yeah I think this is
why I end up watching porn with if I
don't see a guy's face and um also a lot
of girl on girl porn because it's a
girl's pleasuring each other so it feels
a lot more like up my alley because as
soon as a girl does anything for a dude
I'm like [ __ ] it up
enough enough
I do agree with you on that like a man's
face is the last thing I want to see
like the heads should be cut off keep
them headless keep them headless yeah
bag over their heads it's great like
even if remember when we talked about
like having like a rub and tug but for
women oh my God wait how does that work
oh yeah part of like the job description
for the man would be like are you okay
with you know staying headless like and
putting like wait it should be visible
neck up it should be like the mass
singer where they're like
costumes like oh they have that really
100 it's called furries oh yeah I mean I
think I've lived literally anything and
they will have it in porn like any anime
any like TV any movie literally like a
[ __ ] children's cartoon they will
have sexualized that and you can find
literally anything yeah there's Family
Guy porn it's pretty good okay
[Applause]
I hate the hell Isles is a freak though
I love her that this is bent over and
spread disrespectful to Lois Carlos I'm
never watching Family Guy with you again
you are so I've never seen Family Guy to
go maybe twice
oh my God anything else Kyle we
um I think we covered a lot
uh was this my list no this is our
general oh so I was like Pete and
emirata
do you want to talk about no I was just
like I don't know why that would be on
my list Karen's our former pretty girls
can I hear your hot take on that please
well that was there's no real take it
was just this Tick Tock I saw that said
like why women
like like they I don't know how I feel
about this this is not my opinion but
that like if you're a Karen it's because
like you're used to being treated the
way you were treated like when you were
young and beautiful and that like now
you're mad at society which is a pretty
misogynous taste what about male Cairns
because does that apply no because I
feel like Karen is specifically for
women that term Bobby is a male Karen
yeah but I still feel like they don't
get the same hate yeah same heat but
also it's it's not as the same
representation like the term Karen yeah
just feels like it like I don't know
what a Bobby is that's just my ex
but a Bobby could become a term no I
don't think Bobby is the correct name
for a male Karen I think it's like a
I I forget the name but they someone has
come up with it oh wait what are the
Intel names or like a chat there's a
Chad yeah is yeah Chad is like I feel
like Chad is more like a that's like the
jawline bro dude that's what every
insult wants to be they want to be a
Chad right and then what are the girls
that they hate they all have specific
names it's like a Becky or some [ __ ]
Alexis
Stacy it's a Stacy okay my ex-boyfriend
was like a very interested in incel
culture he's not an Intel
um and so he would always like be like
looking on Reddit and then telling me
this stuff what's a Stacy Stacy the
Stacy is the girl that like is the hot
girl who doesn't want anything to do
with them and they like hate the Stacy's
right and she [ __ ] Chad she [ __ ] Chad
and here's the Becky this is Becky who
does she [ __ ] loose baggy clothing to
hides nerdy bun
natural look five dollar backpack wants
to [ __ ] Chad
wage job so basically the Becky is he is
probably the girl that they think should
be [ __ ] in cell
you don't they want to [ __ ] Chad and so
they're always just getting um rejected
oh like everyone else's friends are
white Knights that defend her stupid
opinions online they said that not me
feminists needy will likely dye hair
green or pink oh God average six out of
ten this is brutal it's I feel like I'm
reading my biography let's Chad dominate
her for Stacy and she cucks every man
hates basic [ __ ] like Becky always
has attention enjoys alone time shows
off her body online because she knows
she can make big money off virgin loser
okay kind of obsessed I need to take a
picture of the shows off Body online to
make money off of Virgin lifters
this is so it's like it's clearly satire
but like people actually believe this
right yeah I yeah they're like
exaggerating it but I think that's what
people believe yeah they spelled
luscious wrong so they're idiots
l-u-s-h-e yes
[ __ ] box
um anyways Eileen thank you so much for
taking the time and chatting with us
thanks for having me video
um it feels nice to just have like a
conversation candidly about mental
health and yeah because
we're we're very mentally ill so we're
working on it I do think comedy it's
like if you're drawn to Comedy like
it's coming from a place of pain yeah
and so it's good to have these
conversations and we appreciate you like
sharing and being vulnerable with us so
thank you yeah and where can people find
more of you yeah so my Instagram is just
my first name Eileen so like the song
Come On Eileen
and then my podcast is going mental with
Eileen Kelly
and yeah I'll send it to you guys you
can put it in the show notes or
something okay cool we will thank you so
much yeah and we will see you guys next
week for an all new episode of trash
Tuesday bye guys
[Music]